what is happening reject nation I'm Greg
Alba
I'm Andrew so we're gonna film the
review for the defenders right after
this but got plenty of requests for
injustice to minor back to trailer
introducing Black Manta trailer and I
was like you know what why divide them
up
why get more views by dividing them up
let's just put it all together with one
video you're so thoughtful I'm so
thoughtful or I don't do anything for
views like every youtuber that you want
them to be like DC it's why I'm wearing
my defender shirt
at the Red Hood looks like I couldn't
count sub-zero
it's got a thunder readin that's black
man all right yeah Black Manta giving
off some for bribes
yeah
[Music]
apartment oh man no ID was gonna be
pardon this
that sounds like a fun dlc that's a
great deal see he looks a little funky
but what the hell man I'm so glad you
could play his elbow oh that's the wrong
Pearlman one but I don't think it sounds
like a guy who's trying to be the ron
perlman that works for me now we're a
it's close to Ron Perlman that's fine
with me before David Harbor redefines it
hopefully me hopefully he does a good
enough job to redefine by the way Andrew
he's played all of injustice - he's
quite ycs meet it and I have versed
people on it and I am not that good but
I played injustice 1 I beat it twice and
it's a lot of fun it's visually it's so
incredible and the story it's actually
it's very engaging it's got a lot of
human death and emotion yeah for a video
game - and like I said the visuals just
really pull you in because incredible
looks cinematically but really I played
the story for a half-hour before I had
to give the controller back to Tony
let's watch the Black Manta do it
there's an alcohol reference
Oh lasting rays
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that Jon Stewart anyways like John yeah
but more blood than I'm used to it from
injustice oh I love his combat I loves
ya his skills are awesome I want to see
him versus it man
yeah come on do your cool finishing move
here should have a star side the better
and Brainiac in the various he means
business
look at that doing the visuals really
yeah
so listen I'm gonna make things as clear
as possible I don't really know jack
about Black Manta but what I can tell
you from seeing the fighting style here
I love it all he's a skilled martial
artist he's got the blades he's got the
ability to hover above people like his
jetpack thing he's got the laser beams
he's just full-on like Marshall is a
martial artist type Iron Man thingy Adam
and quiet yeah I should say add-in Iron
Man did not piss off DC fans Aquaman
kill his dad yeah yeah so basically the
character of Black Manta he was first
introduced in the comics in August of
1967 by created by Bob Haney and Nick
Hardy and the first comic they
introduced him in was issue number 35
between to dooms yeah I know you know
what's interesting about this character
though is he grew up as a youth he was
autistic he grew up in Baltimore
Maryland and he was very fascinated by
the sea and one day he gets kidnapped
and he's forced to work on a boat
actually it's an unspecified amount of
time they don't really say but one day
when he's working on this on this ship
he sees Aquaman riding with a bunch of
dolphins and he tries to signal for help
Aquaman doesn't see him in one day
he has to fend for his life against one
of his tormentors and he kills him and
he kind of just sees the see as very
emotional ascend and he feels that
Aquaman is that representative of the
sea so he makes it his mission to kind
of become the master of the scene he
rivals that of even ocean master you
know Aquaman's brother armed right so
but I think this version that they're
going with Greg which you're very
familiar with is the new 52 version yeah
everyone because he mentioned that he
killed his father and that's what
happened in that comic book in the new
52 and also it was interesting and that
is Aquaman forms like a whole group
they're called the order and their
mission is to stop is to catch and stop
Black Manta and Aquaman does
inadvertently kill black mantas father
which you can see in this video and in
this clip is why he has that hatred and
I'm so glad I stole this information
from you took all the information man
like we have an iPad in front of us
right now and he's just reading new
script that I wrote from my dear James
Cameron right now I'm like Arnold mt2
and that boat in that car where I'm just
reading the cue cards like dude you're
amazing I give you had a really good job
reading my information what I do without
you when in reality I'm just trying not
to do another sad greg alba video as i
listen it's cuz when you know all the
information I'm sad going I wish I knew
all this information really quick before
we end this I just want to say I did
love seeing Raiden in this too we got to
see Jay Garrick we got to see Jon
Stewart obviously we've already seen
Swamp Thing yeah Hellboy and I had no
idea they were bringing Hellboy dothis
actually with Hellboy he's the one
carrot of kind of question or finishing
move I see I would like to see all that
but my experience with Mortal Kombat and
injustice oftentimes the characters who
are big and thick or not the most fun to
play with they're not very agile they
can yeah so to move they don't really do
much and Hellboy seems like he'd go
either direction where he could be
awesome or he's kind of a letdown to
play with I agree with everything you
just said if the finishing move is
beyond sick which I have a feeling it's
gonna be kind of make up for that in
certain areas but I'm with you know when
you're big
characters sometimes they can be little
laggy little slower they're not as agile
as athletic so you're like I don't have
an advantage really I love rain ever
since well we first got introduced in
the Mortal Kombat games and the Super
Nintendo but I love this character and
seeing him infused into the into the
injustice world
I can't wait in the visuals again it
just looks so incredible in these videos
easily so straight up just doing Mortal
Kombat versus injustice I don't know why
they haven't done that it's like a
full-on MK vs. and John for that me down
for that this is why you don't need to
subscribe to the real rejects you just
got to subscribe and her on the movie
source channel because he clearly knows
his [ __ ] don't subscribe to me I mean if
you don't want to you can I'll be good I
like a number increased why not see I
subscribed in the movie source channel
he's also twitter.com slash a core 711
follow him there he tweets and he hints
to post every once in a while a core 711
as well and you know patreon exists if
you care about that take care